hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play phobia
1.5 apparently there's something up
there they're really like is something
up there there's something legitness up
there so let's go say hi hello my name
is markiplier I play 50 games on the
inner butts and people watch them I know
what hats it's referring to it's that
one oh my god [ __ ] what did i do what
did I do
you
oh oh oh oh oh okay I'm back oh good it
didn't leave me too far apparently I hit
some button that said I didn't want to
continue oh my god that'd be like the
worst scare I've ever had in my life oh
my god I'll it was so horrible I don't
know what it was I still don't know I
didn't get a good look at it oh my god
huh
was that a beautiful princess come to
save me okay all right
oh my god all right I know what I need
to do I know what I need to do this
there was a ladder in the UH the outside
area through all the snow I just got a
knock you cornered like that oh god oh
my god oh my god she was a horrible no
offense lady but um oh I got one thing I
really don't want to know I really don't
want to Oh blood bladder better get the
ladder oh no don't tell me what I gotta
do we're gonna go touch it first be like
I need a ladder oh good golly that's all
because I didn't reverse generate my way
out of that bathroom is it you come
barreling up that staircase again I'm
gonna be very upset
okay okay oh I got a toe
okay go go go go go go go go go go Oh Oh
God
thank you oh god it's right behind is
right behind me I notice oh yeah gah gah
don't care you dick okay all right then
that's a bit too much excitement for the
beginning of the episode don't you think
my lovely audience out there doesn't
appreciate that kind of oh wait you love
that
lovely people okay oh yea this game is
much improved from the last one why did
the drawing lead me here what does that
person who drew it trying to show me
well there's a lady that drew it the one
that's trying to murder me face off oh
she's such a beautiful delightful
darling oh the light of my life
also the remover of my life the
Eviscerator of my life don't tell me
she's gonna find her way up there I did
kind of leave the ladder leading up
oh we have here what is this I didn't
get to read that you didn't show me the
hell wait what is it oh I get it I moved
it okay I didn't I get to see that
someone with eagle vision write in the
comments what the hell was said there I
saw that shadows like room oh yeah
yeah I don't know what they did to
improve the SPS creator engine but it is
much much better I mean look at it it's
got cast shadows palm mapping it looks
great I don't know if that technically
is bump mapping but it looks guy like
snow unlocked I didn't know his unlock
luck
hello hi somebody here someone here gosh
I wonder what happened to the scientists
man
okay bunch of notes
I'm definitely infected by the mixture I
was driven somewhat driving somewhere I
don't know for the life of me remember
where when suddenly I simply forgot how
to drive to saw the Sun any knowledge
how to operate a car vanish from my mind
causing me to crash a damn thing in a
ditch somewhere it seems like I'm stuck
here now I need to start working on some
kind of antidote fast
why didn't I work on an antidote in the
test subject started showing the
symptoms whoever it was is or was and
wherever I got it from all of my
knowledge of the mixture is fading out
of my mind and I need to read back my
reports in order to manufacture the
antidote it doesn't make it any easier
with the reports being scattered all
around the place I'm finished I can't
continue working on the antidote because
I forgot the code for the lab door why
is there code even why is his lab base
hidden in the basement what experiment
can even be so important that I went as
far as using a human test subject what
was this experiment even okay
there's a hidden laboratory in the
basement it doesn't sound well f---ing
but I have to worth a look you don't
have an absence you
so uh what see ah what's the code their
breath
what's it code oh oh my god oh no no oh
god damn it [ __ ] you oh my god
oh you're gonna make me loser ah what
happened what happened did I fall did I
fall to the floor oh that is a
creepy-looking mother humper oh I do not
like that guy I still haven't gotten a
good look at him kind of got a look at
him there but oh no no no it crashed ah
okay I'll be back in a bit
damn it whoa alright guys sorry about
that I'm back now alright we seem to be
in some sort of uh-oh red haze but that
has been fixed okay so I did fall
through the floor looks like all the way
down to the bottom oh it feels like I
broke something even as Pierce I
survived the drop at least some that
thing didn't jump after me the hidden
laboratory is the only place I haven't
searched yet the code for the door has
to be written down in here somewhere why
in here somewhere even though it looks
rather dastardly an evil genius II I
need to keep writing these down to
remind myself unfortunately I had
written the code down somewhere I just
can't remember anymore but I also just
wrote it down on a note because I can't
seem to memorize it but where's the note
now I'm sure I left it in the dining
room somewhere okay knowing me the lab
must fire exit but even I remember I
doubt I can get in that way what huh
okay wait a minute this report one five
the six so if I try one five something
six it might work maybe that's it okay
hang on was that knowing me the lab must
and have a fire exit somewhere okay
alright so anyway one five six is my
best bet so far but he said to go in the
kitchen so let's go in
is that thing gonna be ever me I had an
accident the lab today I was trying to
give another dose to the test subject
when even being tied up she managed to
knock the needle out of my hands I think
I might have got a small drop of it in
my eye oh oh that's how it happened so
is that thing still here mind the top
floor okay so that thing hopefully is
trapped in the Attic
I gotta go down the kitchen okay so I
gotta look for a note kitchen 1968 maybe
that's it one five six oh no no no no no
no no set the kitchen I didn't see it
all the kitchen that wasn't the kitchen
excuse me are you kidding me
excuse me it's your night all right how
about it enough here with your sad
kitchen kitchen kitchen kitchen
something in the kitchen
is this even the kitchen there's nothing
in here there's nothing in the kitchen a
bunch of lying losers lying losers
something here there's a bunch of papers
but nothing to read damn it all right I
guess I'm just going down ah
where is it
oh yeah it's over here sorry sorry my
brains a little scrambled from what just
happened so I'm gonna just take a little
bit of a breather you need to find out
the code before he uses dammit
where am I supposed to go oh my kitchen
I thought I did anyway now let me go
back to that room again because maybe
there was something else that I missed
there might have been another noter or
something wrong
the might have meant something important
with it saying that there might have
been a fire escape or something clock
thing some kind of medical diploma
Edward Rupert Frank felt what a stupid
name Oh AHA there we go there's
something behind this beer yeah got it
I found the code I had written down in a
self portal I need a ride home come on
oh whoa oh oh oh I'd written down behind
myself Oh Oh God probably not a good
sound but I know where self Mordred is
it's upstairs it's um Ok Go Go Go Go Go
Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go oh god I
was wandering around this place for a
while it'sit's this creepy ass thing up
here Oh God oh no no Mizzou a carpark I
need something cutter oberoth up with a
knife in the kitchen I have that big-ass
knife now make sense I guess I think
baby oh god okay I hear you stomping
around his snow stop it around in the
show let's get the knife but work in the
work it'll work why I shot
so I'm gonna closest hey Google cuz a
knife get that I'm gonna dive dive dive
got it it works
you look so mean to stealing in the
doorway okay I'm good I'm good I'm good
I'm good good good ship one nine three
mmm how is that helpful
what am I supposed to do what am I
supposed to do 193 uh uh nine three what
it's easy enough to try them all oh so
good for so good one nine three what was
there another digit that was cut off
no I thought I heard okay let's just try
let's go down to the basement I don't
have any thoughts one nine three pin one
ninety please go try it goes right all
right right right you know I'd rather
have the choir of demons right now oh
one nine three one one
no no one nine three six I'm not doing
this in order M one nine three nine one
nine three seven [ __ ]
threes five [ __ ] three two come on come
on
I got her did it open wide oven no was i
dying did I die still alive okay good
good good for me oh good it's good it's
good it's good good good I was had total
confidence all right haha the very last
one that I try I'm an idiot okay so
anyway that's all the time pick up for
this way thank you all so much for
watching click here taste for what it is
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye
Oh
ah
but